you are super good at singing you I do
owe my career I think too you told me
backstage he and Megan actually voted
around 7,000 times for me that's right
no but you do you have a new podcast
right yes Megan and I have a new podcast
called in bed with Nick and Megan are
you literally in bed doing it depends on
the guest doing the interview and the
bed you're doing so what do y'all talk
about well sometimes it's very funny
depending on the guest sometimes it's
very serious sometimes it's just us
sometimes Megan's bandmate from Nancy
and Beth herb and Stephanie hunt that
joins us as sort of a wacky sidekick
we just have everything we have a great
scoop of friends and we bring them one
at a time and put them in our bed this
is actually Megan for 20 years or 20
years yeah
[Applause]
she doesn't have great eyesight that's
number one I think the secret is a sense
of humor
intimacy swallow your ego if you're
gonna promise somebody to stay together
for your whole lives then you have to
make some compromises and say you know
what okay I will not put mayonnaise on
the chicken cordon bleu but it's good
you win tonight you win honey that's
good man that's awesome it's such a rare
thing I think for somebody to stay with
in especially in this industry
you've got spotlights on you that's hard
it is yeah that's so I I come in oh
that's amazing
thank you I appreciate it yeah I love
you too we're so perfect
thank you we have a lot of fun together
yes it's such a great show how is this
season anything different from the first
this season well you know the biggest
difference is the contestants on season
two have seen season one so like like
testings on Survivor these days they
know how to game the show they're like
okay by season five or there's gonna be
a merge and we're gonna have to change
our bar buffs and they're just filled
with liars
they are they yes I watched this show my
sister and mother are obsessed with it I
feel like all you do is survive me it'd
just be called lying it is yes lines
good yes yes there's not so much lying
on this show but if you don't like
something that's great the glue gun
doesn't lie I love what y'all do it's a
fascinating what y'all do like what you
can create like that quickly it's the
contestants on this show are astonishing
their creativity I mean Amy and I we
love our jobs because we just stand
there and watch brilliant people make
magic
yeah and that our job is to say look at
this yeah this is amazing yeah and they
say here's money can I get you a
sandwich do you have like a favorite
item from the show that someone's made
oh there's a lot of those but this
season there was one there was one I
don't want to give any spoilers but
there was one that I thought was so
magnificent it moved me to tears oh that
is such a tease yeah it was really it
was it was an art project that you could
enter oh you could walk and maybe earn I
don't know we'll have to eat a lot you
have to watch and see I'm actually very
excited about it but there also was a
was it called the she shed she shells
and salted caramel there's some rules
well we're actually donating one of them
on the show oh no yeah we're gonna be
donating one of them they were pretty
cool right they were amazing yeah I mean
it's not only are they brilliant and
creative but all of the contestants the
things that because I can make some
things I can make furniture which is why
I'm on the show but what they can make
in six hours would take me six days or
six weeks yeah that's what's amazing but
you're pretty talented like I've seen
some of yours so yeah you're pretty
tough you're being humble what I don't
mean yes many people can hammer and nail
I I'm not good at that I just I can
hammer a nail and grow a good mustache
[Applause]
piece that you've made you know there's
two canoes on the perks and Rick show
that Ron Swanson uses those I made both
of those and I'm very proud of those but
the best thing I made was a little
heart-shaped walnut box that housed the
ring with which I proposed to my wife
and spoiler alert it worked it was an
effective piece of woodworking and it
was pre 9/11 so you can still take
linseed oil on the airplane and sneak
into the bathroom and do a couple final
finished coats
yes you're on an airplane going it's
gonna be perfect about an organization
that you it's called wood works
wood works yeah wo uld that's right yeah
my my wood shop in Los Angeles partners
with this this company called wood works
it's a nonprofit that helps people on
Skid Row or homeless people just get a
leg back up because often people are
just dealt a bad hand of cards in life
often it has to do with our crazy
healthcare system or they're born into
it yeah or they're born into it where
they all they want to do people just
want to be a responsible citizen but
sometimes it's hard to get that first
leg up if you don't have an address or
you don't have a social security number
and so you can sign up at Woodworks to
perform labor where you're making
cutting boards or coasters or other
woodworking items and what works instead
of paying you in cash they pay you with
something you need to get going like a
suit of clothes or a pair of glasses so
it's and then the best thing is that a
prospective job employer can call
Woodworks and we can say oh yeah Julie
showed up for two weeks she was sober
like she give her a job she's a good
lady and so it helps people get going
and get on on their way back to finding
an address of that's a huge thing to
have somebody to call like for your
resume and I have a very embarrassing
confession I did I told him backstage
but in 2011 I tweeted I didn't just
tweet I begged to be on Park just so I
could be in the scene with Ron Swanson
because I was obsessed here's the thing
I even own that I was a horrible actor
I'm a horrible actor but I but I I have
a lot of spirit and I could have played
a bad actor I didn't even call it's fine
it's fine Amy it's fine you know no but
if I if we could turn back time with
share and and you gave you food or what
do you think I could have played like
maybe maybe like a stage five cleaner
well it's it's a huge compliment first
of all I'm very grateful that you wanted
to be on the show dude it's great so
great there's so many great actors on
the road I was I was grateful to get to
get to go to work every day and I'd say
I think they were you know great comedy
writers you know they look at me and
they say we can make people laugh with
this give that give that guy a coffee
cup oh yeah here we go give him a phone
on his belt all right you know what the
physical comedy is so key it is so great
but I think they would look at you and
they take your strengths and they would
say okay let's let's cast Kelly is a
very enthusiastic wildly enthusiastic
like hurricane of positivity yes and I
think the laugh to get with a Kelly
Clarkson character is someone who would
out Leslie Knope Leslie Knope exactly
you would finally somebody who Leslie
Knope would be like she's too much not
the first time I've heard that probably
not the last my husband says that every
night and after then he says I love you
I will not stop talking until you
subscribe to my youtube channel that's
right and I could talk a lot seriously
not going to stop yep still here not
going anywhere I see you don't walk away
from this